al llamando la respuesta del país al cob
y 19 la lucha contra el cambio climático
y el impulso de la economía rusa en su
discurso anual a la nación vladimir
putin abordó una amplia gama de temas
pese a no mencionar circunstancias
específicas el líder ruso respondió con
fuerza a las crecientes tensiones con
occidente
no queremos quemar puentes
pero si alguien percibe nuestra buena
intención como apatía o debilidad y
pretende quemar esos puentes entonces
deben saber que la respuesta de rusia
será asimétrica rápida y dura
y de aquellos que organicen cualquier
provocación que amenace los intereses
fundamentales de seguridad de rusia se
arrepentirán de sus acciones como nunca
antes una misión julie
una advertencia que se produce en medio
de la concentración militar de rusia
cerca de ucrania que hace saltar las
alarmas en europa pero el kremlin ha
rechazado continuamente las
preocupaciones de su vecino la locución
estuvo centrada en la situación
socioeconómica del país y la pandemia de
kobe 19 haciendo un llamado a la
vacunación masiva para alcanzar la
inmunidad de rebaño
la solución de este problema está en
nuestras y vuestras manos en las manos
de todos los ciudadanos me dirijo una
vez más a todos los ciudadanos rusos con
un llamamiento vacunarse esta es la
única manera de bloquear la pandemia
mortal walk attack
desde cualquier de martín la paz en el
frente interno el presidente ruso no
hizo ninguna referencia a su principal
opositor alexéi navalni que se encuentra
enfermo en prisión mientras putin
hablaba los rusos las calles de todo el
país congregaron masivas manifestaciones
en apoyo a naval mí cientos de personas
han sido detenidas por las fuerzas de
seguridad rusas en a sus seguidores y
buena parte de la comunidad
internacional están pendientes de la
salud del opositor